in welcher situation schließen wir die
tür hinter uns ab weil wir ungestört
sein wollen für ein techtelmechtel weil
man möglicherweise etwas verstecken und
dabei nicht erwischt werden darf oder
weil man möglicherweise plant jemanden
umzubringen er in stuttgart da stellen
sich ermittler derzeit genau diese
fragen zwei promi wirte liegen tot in
dem verbarrikadierten keller einer
pizzeria die leichen sind übel
zugerichtet dieser fall hat wirklich
alle zutaten für einen grusel krimi
jan iv 53 jahre besitzer des edel
italieners und geschäftsführer rosario l
sind tot das ist traurige tatsache was
genau passiert ist im restaurant vale in
der geschwister-scholl-straße in
stuttgart ist allerdings noch völlig
unklar nach einem zeugenhinweis gestern
gegen 15 uhr 50 sind unsere kollegen in
die geschwister scholl straße gefahren
haben dort im untergeschoss des gebäudes
in einem zimmer zwei tote männer
gefunden im alter von 53 jahren beide
leichen wiesen schwere verletzungen auf
nach einer ersten gerichtsmedizinischen
begutachtung sind diese verletzungen bei
beiden durch scharfe gewalt entstanden
die leichen der beiden männer sollen
extrem brutal zugerichtet worden sein
bild erfuhr feuerwehr und polizei
mussten das kellerzimmer aufbrechen die
tür war von innen verriegelt hinter der
tür eine riesige blutlache vermutlich
hatten sich die beiden 53 jährigen
männer gegenseitig mit messern bekämpft
bis aufs blut bis in den tod wir müssen
eben morgen auch das ergebnis der
obduktion abwarten um hinweise zu
bekommen wie die tat abgelaufen ist
derzeit werden weitere personen aus dem
umfeld der beiden toten befragt und die
geschichte die gesicherten spuren von
gestern werden weiter ausgewertet
das motiv bisher reine spekulation jenny
v und sein bruder giuseppe besaßen
mehrere italienische restaurants in
besten lagen in stuttgart im edlen per
baku wechselte erst vor wenigen wochen
der pächter möglich dass es auch neue
pläne mit dem vale gab war ein
geschäftlicher streit der grund für das
tödliche gemetzel im keller wenn sich
zeugen
zur verfügung stellen dann sollen sie
sich an die kriminalpolizei wenden jan
iv und rosario m 2 große namen in der
stuttgarter gastroszene jetzt sind sie
tot ein bizarrer doppelmord unter höchst
mysteriösen umständen
und mein kollege hagen stegmüller steht
vor der mysteriöse pizza bude bzw dem
mysteriösen pizza lokal ja lieber hagen
sag mal wie kommt die polizei das frage
ich mich die ganze zeit darauf eine tür
aufzubrechen also links zwei leichen der
keller ist abgesperrt wie kommt man
darauf dort überhaupt zu suchen
es ging so dass am nachmittag
angestellte bemerkt haben dass die
beiden geschäftsführer rosario und
johnny sich ins untergeschoss bezogen
haben
dort kam es dann offenbar auch zu einem
lautstarken streit es ging laut herrmann
hat aber zunächst dieser sache nicht
diese beachtung geschenkt wie wie es ist
sich später herausstellte nachdem dann
später stille einkehrt und jeder der
eine noch der andere wieder zurück zur
arbeit kamen hat ein angehöriger
nachgeschaut nach unten und hat eben die
tür verschlossen vorgefunden
und natürlich nachdem zuvor dieser
krawall zu hören war ist denn natürlich
sorgenvoll hat er sich an die polizei
gewandt und den rest hat ja
polizeisprecher wird man eben erklärt
die polizei kam von allein nicht ein
musste die feuerwehr zur hilfe holen mit
einem brecheisen hat die feuerwehr die
tür geöffnet und dann die beiden leichen
entdeckt welche theorien gibt es denn
jetzt zum tathergang also warum
schließen die beiden sich da ein das
kann doch verschiedene gründe haben ich
habe es gerade schon angesprochen wenn
man da ungestört sein oder hat möglich
weise der eine geplant den anderen
umzubringen und der andere auch ist das
im affekt erstanden nehmen uns mit
welche theorien dass möglicherweise
schon gibt
nun ein teil der theorien wurden ja
schon genannt die wahrscheinlichste ist
eben das ist ein streit gab dass beide
mit dem messer aufeinander losgegangen
sind es ist zwar unwahrscheinlich
normalerweise überlebten mindestens
einer in diesem fall könnte es
tatsächlich so sein dass ich beide
nahezu gleichzeitig diese schweren
verletzungen zugefügt haben eine weitere
theorie die die polizei verfolgt ist
eben noch dass der eine dem anderen
schwere verletzungen zugefügt hat und
sich dann unter umständen nachher selber
gerichtet hat sicher ist für uns aber